[Music]
let's go to
melanie in san francisco hey melanie how
are you
i'm doing great how are you guys good
how come
john and i helped today well
i've been debating on calling for a long
time i just
got onto dave ramsey probably two months
ago from one of my
agents in my brokerage that i work for
and i am
28 years old i have two kids under
two and i've been married for five years
we've been together for eight
and i just kind of hit a spot where
i found no motivation i don't feel like
i'm worth a lot
like i'm just a mom and i know that
sounds so
loaded i struggle with anxiety a lot and
i've been struggling lately with
self-doubt
and being a new realtor with nothing
under my belt it's
hard to get out there to get your first
listing or get your first buyer
and i lately i've been doing this before
i got my license in october and i had my
son a week later so i've been really
doing this for
maybe seven months like all the time
and i just don't know if
if it's right for me i don't know i go
back to
this is what i worked so hard for i went
to school i paid this
off it's all ready but i just
it's the self-doubt that gets me it's
my husband is i love him to death and
i'll spend the rest of my life defending
him but
he just has no goals he has no
aspirations
he's just happy and content and i'm
mom and he's dad he goes to work he
comes home and
i do everything and i hate to say that
but
uh i don't know how do i go about
getting my husband on the same page
about getting debt free because i i
guess i'm just looking for insight
yeah melanie first of all i just it's
funny even on the break
john and i were talking and i was
talking about um just in matina's
journey we had
two kids a year and a half apart and i
remember that year
i remember that year like it about
nothing
yes yes it is it about broke us
and and and i hear it in your voice my
husband and i are at right now
and i talked to him the other day i i
broke
and i said i'm not happy something's
something
i'm not happy and i i i was such a fun
outgoing social butterfly i would talk
to anybody and now
i'm just i'd rather just stay home you
know with my kids and
yeah i just i just i don't know maybe
i'm wrong for calling i don't know
no you're not at all i'm so glad you
called i want i want john to take this
this is his specialty but i just want to
encourage you one thing
because i was literally just in your
shoes a few years ago and i know
everybody says it melanie but it's true
this is a season this is where you are
this is not who you are your season does
not define you
you are in a season of little kids that
are
absolutely consuming you are exhausted
that is where you are that is not who
you are and i promise you
i promise you it will get easier
john can can take this from the anxiety
and the self-doubt angle but i'm just
saying with the little kids like i hear
it in your voice
i was you and i swear as i sit here
today it does
get easier you are still that fun girl
and you will go out and be fun again
you are just in a season that is
exhausting
and i promise you it will get easier i
can take all
of the clinical expertise on planet
earth and none of that matters
like hearing from a mom who's just been
there
my husband and i also too i i don't like
talking about because i don't want
anybody to feel pity for me because i
don't want any pity
we lost our son at 41 weeks
during delivery uh four years ago
and since that moment happened we
we just kind of coexist that's what it
feels like to me i love him to death and
he
is my husband yes but it's we just
co-exist at this point and i just i need
to i want to save my marriage and i want
to get debt free and buy a house and do
all these things but
that's right it's very difficult so
you're taking on
the world right now and it's like your
boat is sinking
and you're also thinking about a
mortgage and you're thinking about where
your kids are going to go to college and
right now you've got to get to shore
okay you are exhausted
and that's focus number one so i want
you to
get some time with your husband y'all
get away
and find somebody to come sit with you
with your little kids
you can get 48 hours and i want you just
to be with each other
this this christie's right this
conversation who we're going to become
and what we're going to be all that
your body is going to become yours again
your heart's going to become yours again
your mind will become yours again
and then you will have a season where
you have solid ground you can work on
your marriage that's not today today
is about survival
you got this and we'll be praying for
you melanie